du côté de washington souvenez vous le 6
janvier dernier le capitole pris
d'assaut par les pros trump et bien ce
samedi ils étaient de retour au capitole
placée sous très haute sécurité une
nouvelle fois par crainte de
débordements on retrouve thomas bonnet
là bas pour un point complices
environ 200 voire 300 personnes se sont
rassemblées ce samedi ici devant le
capitole pour demander justice pour ceux
qui ont été arrêtés lors des événements
du 6 janvier dernier ici même au
capitole il estime que beaucoup ont été
arrêtés alors qu'ils n'avaient mis
commis aucune violence ils dénoncent
aussi leurs conditions de détention pour
certains écoutez les témoignages
recueillis ce samedi ici à washington
les gens ont fait irruption dans le
capital parce qu'il voulait renverser
une élection démocratique dans laquelle
ils pensaient avoir été trompé nous
avons donc un terrain d'entente je suis
du côté démocratique du spectre
électorale je suis aussi pour la
construction d'une unité et d'une
démocratie forte donc je suis très
heureux qu'ils disent aussi vouloir une
démocratie forte et transparente parce
que c'est ce dont nous avons besoin
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour moi
que la réforme électorale soit le
problème de droits civiques qui
connaissent une intention grandissante
aujourd'hui dans le pays
c'était important pour moi de venir
aujourd'hui car plus de 600 américains
ont été inculpés dans les événements du
6 janvier des dizaines d'entre eux sont
toujours enfermés et la façon dont ils
sont traités est un scandale les
personnes qui n'ont pas été incriminés
sont retenus sans raison ils sont
isolées jusqu'à 23 heures par jour est
la seule façon pour eux de parler alors
avocat ou de recevoir des visites
séparées ou bout par téléphone ils sont
soumis à des conditions vraiment injuste
beaucoup de gens avaient peur c'était
une tactique d'intimidation
on leur a dit que c'était un piège que
s'il venait il allait être arrêté et les
gens ont peur des services de police du
fbi et du ministère américain de la
justice
vous avez entendu quelques unes des
raisons qui pourraient expliquer la
faible affluence lors de cette
manifestation ici à près du capitole il
faut aussi noter que l'ancien président
donald trump avait pris ses distances
avec cet appel à rassemblement
expliquant que cela serait perdant dans
tous les cas parce qu'en cas de faible
affluence les manifestants seraient
moqués et s'ils étaient nombreux il n'y
aurait une forte pression de la part des
autorités en tout cas aucun débordement
ne s'est déroulée ce samedi il faut dire
qu'il y avait un très important
dispositif de sécurité qui avait été à
déployer avec beaucoup de policiers des
policiers anti-émeutes aussi qui ont
encadré cette manifestation qui s'est
donc déroulée dans le calme on est loin
des menaces que faisait planer la
plupart des médias américains y compris
les autorités de la ville de washington
qui avait tenu une conférence de presse
ce vendredi voilà donc pour cette
manifestation que beaucoup pourront
qualifier d'échec parce qu'effectivement
il n'y avait finalement assez peu de
supporters de donald trump qui se sont
rassemblés ce samedi